Tons of beloved Nintendo characters make
their big-screen debut in "The Super Mario
Bros. Movie," but viewers have noticed two missing
fan favorites who consider themselves number one.
Warning: Spoilers for "The
Super Mario Bros. Movie" ahead.
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie" gets a ton of
mileage out of video game lore, and there are
Easter eggs pretty much everywhere you look. For
example, a Toad blows into a video game cartridge,
like how people would do with the NES or
N64 when it wouldn't work for some reason.
"This thing work?"
"Yes, you just have to blow into it."
However, at a brisk 90-minute runtime,
there are some bits of Mario mythology
that didn't make it into the movie,
and perhaps nothing is as disappointing
as the exclusion of Wario and Waluigi.
Granted, many other characters in the orbit
of Mario have yet to make their big-screen
animated debut, such as Daisy and Bowser
Jr. But Wario and Waluigi have a unique,
idiosyncratic appeal to them, and people were
no doubt wondering when they were going to
show up. That's especially true since Mario
and Luigi have an antagonistic relationship
with their former co-worker, Spike. He could've
easily been Wario, and Mario fans, along with
people who love the Wario and Waluigi memes all
over social media, would've lost their minds.
But, of course, the two archrivals
of the Mario Brothers could still
get their moment. There are naturally
many places the franchise can go as
far as sequels. The post-credits scene
hints that Yoshi will be involved in some
capacity next time around. Bowser is still
around, though tiny and locked in a cage.
But a sequel should explore other antagonists
and other facets of this realm, and there would
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie," Mario and Luigi got
picked on in their youth. The movies could reveal
that Wario was one of those bullies, though
other stories have usually portrayed him as
They could even be the ones responsible
for letting Bowser out of his imprisonment,
leading to a team-up while potentially
exploring other lands or galaxies.
Making it so that Wario and Waluigi come
from Brooklyn would also be an intriguing
development by forcing Mario and Luigi to
confront their roots. By the end of "The
Super Mario Bros. Movie," the brothers
are living in the Mushroom Kingdom after
finally earning the approval of their father.
They appear to have finally found contentment
in their lives, but their past could
come back to haunt them in a big way.
With decades of games, there's no
shortage of stories to pull from